hello everybody this is Peter Cooper
from the NCBI with me today is Beverly
Underwood from the GenBank submissions
staff today we're going to talk about
16s RNA GenBank submissions the slides
for today are should be available to you
in the handouts section on the right
hand side of your screen so you can
download those there if you want to also
available at our FTP site in the
materials QA directory there and that
compressed URL will take you there okay
so now I'm going to turn the talk over
to Beverly all right thank you Peter and
welcome today we will show you how to
submit your 16s ribosomal RNA data to
NCBI you will learn the fastest route to
submitting and receiving accession
numbers for 16s sequences we will show
you where to access this faster
submission tool we will demonstrate a
submission help you understand the
submission process and provide you with
a pre submission checklist to help your
submission go more smoothly we will
start right away with the demonstration
this is a link to the submission tool
you need to use your NCBI login or
register for a free NCBI account if you
do not yet have one okay we are going to
the submission portal using a link in
the slides now first I need to check the
I am logged in I am not so I'll click
the login button to enter my NCBI
username and password and click sign in
if you do not yet have an NCBI login you
can use this register for an NCBI
account and follow the steps on the page
okay so we are now logged in this is the
GenBank submission portal you can click
on short description and brief
instructions to read brief descriptions
of the types of sequences you can submit
here and the requirements for these
submission types below that our
submissions that you may have already
been you may have already made to start
a new submission click the new
submission button we have started a new
mission at the top of the page is your
sub number this sub number is not an
accession number you should only use
this number for tracking and
corresponding with NCBI until accessions
are assigned this is a submitter page
this page has your contact information
the address on this page will be
displayed on your final GenBank record
throughout this talk I may refer to a
GenBank record as a flat file for this
webinar these mean the same thing if you
are a new user you will need to fill out
the form making sure you have filled in
all the fields with an asterisk if
you're a returned user this form should
be filled out already with the
information you previously provided note
if you are not using a United States
address the state province field is
optional and you may leave it blank so
review this information on the page and
make changes as needed
again this address will be displayed in
the final GenBank record I have looked
over everything on this page and since
my information is correct I will click
continue for this demonstration we are
submitting prokaryotic 16s sequences so
I will select small subunit ribosomal
RNA only 16s rRNA the lowest but you can
see the other submission types that you
can submit through this tool listed here
and we may have webinars on those in the
future below the submission types is a
free text field for the submission title
this field is optional you may use a
submission title to help your track your
submission the submission title is not
displayed in the final gym bank record
and is for your use only for this
demonstration I will leave this field
blank I am done with this page so I will
click continue so we are now on the
sequencing technology page select the
method you use to obtain the sequences
from the options listed on the page or
if your method is not listed select
other and type the method you used in
the provided text box for this
demonstration I will select Sanger
notice you use one of these other
methods you will need to indicate if you
assembled the C
winces and you will be prompted for the
name of the assembly program and version
now we are in the sequences page first
you need to select when you want to
release the sequences to the public
nucleotide database if you want the
sequences to be publicly available as
soon as possible
click release immediately if you are
still working on a publication and do
not want the sequences available for
some time select release on a specified
date for this demonstration I will
select to release on a specified date
April 29th 2017 next you are asked if a
chimera check program was used to check
the sequences chimeric sequences are
formed by the encourage joining of two
or more biological sequences chimeric
sequences are commonly formed during
laboratory procedures to isolate 16s
ribosomal RNA there are publicly
available chimera check programs
designed to identify chimeric sequences
we highly encourage you to perform a
chimera check of your sequences and
remove chimeric sequences from your file
prior to submitting if you did this
analysis you should check yes and
provide the name and version of the
program you used for this demonstration
I will select no please note that all
16s sequences will be screened for
chimeras so your submission will be
delayed if chimeric sequences are found
in the file there is a link in the
submission checklist provided to you
which discusses chimera detection next
it is asked if your sequences are from a
pure cultured or uncultured source you
may be wondering what these options mean
so I will describe some scenarios to
help explain these a pure cultured
strain would be a few isolated strains
on an auger plate and then isolated the
16s from the genome of an individual
strain on the plate an example of an
uncultured sample would be if you
extract a DNA directly from a mixed
environmental sample like a soil or gut
sample and then amplified in sequence to
16s from the mixed DNA sample if you
extracted 16s
rhizoma RNA from a mixed sample and then
introduced the 16s into laboratory 8
coli strain uncultured is still the
appropriate selection I will select pure
culture from my demonstration now it is
time to provide the sequences file but
first let us quickly look at a FASTA
file of multiple sequences if you have
multiple 16s sequences to submit put all
of the sequences into one FASTA file
like this example it is very important
to correctly format the FASTA file each
sequence in the FASTA file has a
definition line which is marked by the
use of the greater than sign this is
followed by the sequence ID in this file
I use the strain identifiers as the
sequence IDs you may use your laboratory
identifiers such as the strain or clone
ID for the sequence IDs but you may also
use sequence week 2 etc the sequence IDs
must be unique and must be less than 25
characters there are limits on what
characters you can use for the sequence
IDs the checklist made available to you
with this webinar contains a link to
FAFSA format help you may also access it
by clicking on the link on the sequences
page here help on FASTA file now I will
upload my fastest file using the choose
file button depending on your web
browser the button may read browse
instead of choose file notice after I
selected the file you saw a you briefly
saw a progress bar indicating the
progression of file upload you will see
something similar when files are
validated larger files take longer to
both upload and validate the file is
uploaded and I have filled out all the
fields on the page so I'll click
continue if you miss a required field
you will get a red arrow with directions
on what you missed as you're clicking
continue the file is validated and the
sequences are checked for some common
problems like vector contamination and
chimeric sequences if your sequences
have these issues you will get
notification on the sequence
this page after your sequences pass
validation you will be prompted for
source information on the source
modifiers page this page is where you
where you will provide your source
metadata let's look the page over
briefly there are short instructions and
an example source modifiers table which
shows the type of information collected
here the required information for your
type of submission is listed but you may
provide more source information to make
your submission more informative to
database users a complete list of valid
source modifiers and descriptions may be
found by clicking on more help with
source modifiers on the source modifiers
page you may obtain a table template to
provide the source information by
clicking on download source modifier
template you can save this file to your
computer and open it for editing the
table can be filled out in a text editor
or a spreadsheet program if you use a
spreadsheet program make sure you save
the file type as text tab delimited
instructions for using a spreadsheet
program can be found at the source
modifiers link here this is a source
modifiers table that I have already
prepared the top row is the header row
with the source modifier labels below
the header row are the corresponding
data rows the table contains the
required information for cultured
prokaryotic submission which includes
the sequence IDs organism names and
unique streams I have also provided
additional isolation source and country
information the organism is the
scientific name of the organism which
provided the sequence genetic material
it can be a genus species name but it
doesn't have to be that specific if you
do not know it the strain is the
alphanumeric stencil code used in your
laboratory for this strain in this file
PM EO 701 and these other codes are the
strain codes the isolation source
describes the local environment where
the sample was obtained the country is
the location where the
organism or a sequence sample is
obtained additional information about
the location within the country may be
included after the country name and a
colon like this one I linked to the
source modifier descriptions is in the
checklist provided to you with this
webinar all of the values in this table
are separated by a tab so this is a tab
delimited table I will now upload this
table using the choose file button on
the page and click continue to validate
my source modifiers file contained a row
with a new organism name because it is
not yet a recognized name I am receiving
a warning the NCBI does not recognize
the name if you receive this morning you
should check the name for typos if there
are no typos in the names and you are
submitting a sequence from a new
organism one organism not yet in the
NCBI taxonomy click continue if there is
a typo follow the directions in the
morning
correct the names in your file and
upload a new file for validation
uploading a new file will overwrite the
previous file the name in this
demonstration is correctly spelled so I
will click continue we are now on the
references page everything you include
on this page will appear in the final
GenBank record or flat file at the top
are the sequence authors the sequence
authors are the names of people who
helped with generating the sequences
names need to be entered with the first
name or given name first followed by the
last or family name so I'll type my name
Beverly Underwood and my colleagues
named Peter Cooper notice as I was
typing a flat file preview appeared on
the right this is a display for you to
review it displays how the names will
appear in the flat file or final GenBank
record if the name in the preview does
not look correct or how you want it to
appear you need to correct it on the
left
you should pay attention to the preview
and correct the names as needed now
provide the publication where you have
or will discuss the data you are
submitting if you do not intend to
publish a paper for these sequences but
you want to make the sequence data
public you may select unpublished and
leave the remaining fields blank if you
will publish or have published select
those appropriate fill in the
information and click continue again all
of the information you provide on this
page will appear in the flat file ok we
are almost done this is the overview
page the final page which displays all
of the information you provided to us on
the previous pages the release date you
selected is indicated near the top of
the summary the contact address for use
in your records is next followed by the
sequence author's references and
sequencing technology the unprocessed
files you uploaded are provided here
along with the feature table file that
was made from the files you provided a
summary of what we have received as well
as any lists of any processing that was
done to your festive files such as
trimming vector of removing sequences
will be summarized in reports here if
nothing was done the report will state
the number of sequences received and the
sequence length range processed fast day
and source files that will be used to
make your GenBank records are listed
last if any sequences were removed or
trimmed because of vector or chimera
those files will contain those edits
after you have reviewed the information
click Submit congratulations we have now
submitted our data to NCBI and I'm going
to go back to my slide now so what
happens after we click Submit after you
click Submit on the overview page your
submission will go into automated
processing where it is further evaluated
for errors such as those listed on this
slide during this time the submission
portal status will either be queued or
processing
I'll pause for a few seconds so I should
read this slide if there are no errors
the submission will quickly receive
accession numbers and you will receive
an email with a link to portal where you
can download the final process splat
files the submission status is processed
and there is a green checkmark if there
are errors you need to correct you will
receive an email shortly after
submission like this one with a link to
your submission click on the link in the
email to be directed to your submission
and portal the status is error and a
report describing the problems in your
submission is posted click on the error
report to read what the problems are you
may click on the headers and the error
report for more information about the
error so these headers here you are
clickable
once you have corrected the FASTA file
or know how to correct the problem click
the fix button and the submission portal
to correct the problems in this mission
and then you can submit to try again so
we have prepared for you resubmission
checklist of information you need to
collect ahead of time to help your
submission go smoothly this checklist
PDF is available to you the handout and
the webinar materials area the checklist
also contains an example flat file with
The Associated submission dialog pages
to show how the information you provide
relates to the forms and the submission
dialogs into the flat file survivin demo
RNA submissions received through this
tool will be processed faster than other
routes larger submissions will take
longer but currently median response
time to accession numbers with final
process records or error reporting is
less than a day but maybe as soon as 10
minutes after clicking submit so we
encourage you to use this tool to get
your data out faster thank you I'll turn
the server to Peter now ok Thank You
Beverly i we have a couple of questions
that I think are worth addressing for
everybody the first one has to do with
the source organism names so the
question is what if this organism name
is unknown what you include in the
source modifier
our table you're going to address it in
two ways one is it just include the most
precise tax and I'm a group that you
know and and I think that's probably
their right answer but if the organism
is completely unknown I'm not sure what
you would do what would you recommend
they do a neck ache and it's completely
and then they can they can use unknown
organism and and we would get that and
ask them we may ask more questions yeah
if it's from an uncultured sample and
you know it's bacterial or are kale you
could you could call it uncultured
bacterium or if it's cultured and you
and you really don't know you could just
call it bacterium I hope that helps okay
now another question that's similar has
to do with this concept of operational
taxonomic units they want to know if
they can basically submit an OT you file
along with mapping files telling you
what sequence goes with which okie you I
think this is one we want to spend a
little time and give a give it this
person as an answer from our taxon amiss
and so we're going to consult with them
and get back to you okay another
question is which software do you
recommend for looking for chimeras you
mentioned what I think well there's a
number of them available and submission
portal now we're using you time to check
for Camaros there's also decipher there
are some publicly available chimera
programs if you search the literature
okay and we'll do one last question and
this has to do with updating your
sequences so one question was about the
specific example was you know you
submitted as unpublished and then you
just you publish later on and you want
to add the publication to the submission
what do you need to do okay so we have a
an update page and okay great so there's
a link which describes how to format
your update for GenBank and so you
should follow the instructions on that
page and that page includes information
on how to change your publication status
from unpublished to publish as well as
updating your sequences festa are your
source modifiers feature information all
sorts of information and then you would
you would email that to
g/b admin which is on the screen right
now GB admin NCBI NLM to nih gov make
sure it's formatted as described on the
update page and include your accession
numbers with your request okay that's
all the questions that we have time for
today but if there are any others in the
questions pod that we didn't get to will
write out the answers of those we'll
make them available on a document that's
going to be in the materials director
that I mentioned we're going to send you
and a follow-up email to let you know
about the recordings and things like
that we'll also send you a link to a
survey monkey we'd like to get some
feedback both about the webinar and
about the submission ok thanks very much
and thanks for coming today
you